bon d'accord à leur vole à voir
maintenant si je me souviens bien se
doit mettre les fourchettes à à droite
et les couteaux à gauche un méchant
quasi mieux c'est tout le contraire les
fourchettes à gauche
les couteaux à droite c'est logique tu
coupes avec ta main droite
oui d'accord oui oui dis moi j'espère
que tes invités vont arriver parce que
mes galettes sont cuites à point déjà à
oui
ça sent bon eh
oui c'est comme chez toi françois rat
quasi mieux c'est très agréable à
entendre parler ainsi casimir je viens
de rencontrer le facteur il a beaucoup
de travail il a demandé qu'on n'attende
pas il nous rejoindra plus tard bon
alors ces galettes beaucoup mais elles
sont dorée à souhait nous allons nous
régaler tu sais que casimir m'a beaucoup
aidé en rien ne serait prêt sans lui les
deux galettes sont totalement
casimir a demandé que j'en améliore une
en ajoutant quelques sardines et
quelques cornichons
heureusement il en avant une autre pour
nous plus finir merci à toi c'est très
gentil de nous accueillir chez toi pour
l'anniversaire de monsieur du snav c'est
la moindre des choses encore là monsieur
de ce nom
il est très en retard ça lui ressemble
pas du tout ça je ne pouvons pas
commencer le goûter près écoute on
pourrait peut-être aller chercher oui ça
vaudrait mieux casino d'evian avec moi
bannon coûte j'aimerais mieux rester là
pour un pour surveiller les galettes et
casimir il faudrait mieux être deux moi
j'irai voir chez lui et toi bon sens la
durée au jardin parce que peut-être
qu'il s'est trompé de lieu de rendez
vous nous tenons jambon bas puisque
quasiment ne veut pas venir moi je vais
t'accompagner france soir là j'en
profiterai pour prendre un couteau chez
moi nous n'avons rien pour couper les
galettes a laissé tout al'air casino ne
te brûle pas et il ne laisse pas tomber
ce cas dans le four a enfin julie tu
sais très bien que je suis là le
meilleur cuisinier de lille
incroyable enfin quand auront-ils
confiance en moi il me donne toujours
des conseils comme comme si j'étais un
enfant
vraisemblable en
or la juge lui aura quand même pu
prévenir que ce four était allumé
une cigarette
fumée
et l'odeur
j'ai une faim de monstres bien il ya un
problème si j'arrête le four maintenant
elle est garée devant refroidir si je
les laisse plus longtemps elles vont
brûler ce serait dommage parce que les
galettes c'est quand même bien meilleur
show
je vais goûter celle là c'est la mienne
existe un petit morceau
délicieux
je me demande si c'est l'eau aux amandes
est possible après tout celle là j'ai le
droit de la goûter c'est la mienne
voyons voir l'autre juste un petit
morceau
je vais un peu abîmée je vais essayer de
la de couper sa de le couper droit
à vous de geler complètement écrasées
julie va être furieux si elle voit ça ça
y'est j'entends monsieur du snob qui
arrive oh la la
ne vous en faites pas pour moi je vais
trouver une solution
coucou c'est moi et ça je suis vert doté
pétri de confusion pour ce petit retard
merdeux enterrement je retrouve plutôt
rouge de chaleur oui et puis vous ne
pourriez pas passer par la porte comme
tout le monde et puis vous savez que
l'on vous attend depuis une heure je
suis désolé casini où j'avais
complètement oublié le vernissage de mes
meilleurs amis oui c'est le le sculpteur
molmy il fait des sculptures de la mie
de pain
enfin j'ai dû serrer les mains de tous
les invités voici j'espère que françois
julie ne m'en voudront pas pour ce petit
retard mais si au contraire ils sont
absolument furieux il trouve
inadmissible que vous arriviez aussi un
retard un goûter préparé spécialement
pour vous mais où sont ils eh bien je me
julie est allé chercher là pas grand
couteau par un grand couteau pour un
pour vous couper les oreilles en pointe
comme un âne
comme en beaucoup plus plaisir c'est au
vermont points 4 comment un âne avec un
couteau avec un couteau et ça me coupe
les oreilles oui et jouer la somme est
devenue complètement folle peut-être
mais je suis sûr qu'elle le fera elle
est tellement furieuse vous et ça sauve
et vous vite je vous le conseille ils
vont pas tarder à remplir
alors
où
tu sais qu impose yeux tout le temps
ils sont trés d'une pression avait tout
exprès si je n'avais jamais remarqué
oui mais tu appréhendes izieu magnifique
tu
léonard merci
je pense vraiment et continue vers mac
os au
[Musique]
regard envoûtant
elle est un art je t'en prie je suis
content
nota je déchirais je voulais justement
te demander si tu pouvais me prêter et
tout se passe t'il tu as une poussière
dans l'oeil
c'est tout l'effectif charles de vista
je sors mon mouchoir je suis un expert
pour ce genre d'opération messieurs
martin oui on est un vieux garçon est un
grossier personnage
vieux garçon grossi personnage je ne
comprends pas et pourtant mon mouchoir
[Musique]
il n'était pas l' un jardin on n'a pas
vu chez lui né au port on l'a vu venir
on dirait qu'ils sont ici et bien ouais
il sort justement ici comment il n'est
pas resté pour son goûter d'anniversaire
non non non il il a été tellement vexé
de ne pas vous prouver là qu'il a pris
les deux galettes et il s'est sauvé en
courant de gala les bains tu ne vas pas
expliquer vous étiez cette attitude de
me surprendre la part de monsieur du
snop s'est pas du tout dans son
caractère tu dis que tu l'as vu partir
d'ici
et je n'ai vraiment pas eu le temps de
lui expliquer quoi que ce soit bien
julie nous allons lui demander des
explications essayant de rattraper 10 de
la valeur
vous avez vu mon habileté
ils ne seront jamais aussi moi qui ai
mangé les deux galets
mais l'exagèrent prendre les deux
galettes il aurait pu au moins nous en
laisser et
julie où il se cache dans ton qui
inscrit monsieur du jeune homme données
immédiates là bas il fait me terminé à 3
nuls à gauche mais bien comme belle
foulée wim également sortir de mon
casque et me rendre ces deux galettes
me suis dit qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire de réécouter nom n'est
tout de même pas manger les deux
galettes mai mais quelle est cette
histoire de galettes enfin les deux
galettes que vous avez prises chez
casimir
mes chers amis je n'ai rien pris du
temps ses côtés mia qui m'a dit que nous
pourchasse y est comme couper les
oreilles en pointe parce que j'étais en
retard au rendez vous akale anniversaire
je m'en souviendrai j'vous jure
et bien moi j'ai tout compris
les immigrés inventé cette histoire est
accusé monsieur du snob la n'y a plus de
galettes il est tellement gourmand il
n'a pas que dans notre retour les
galettes les à dévorer tout
bravo françois tu es vraiment un grand
défi mais alors ce qui m'ennuie c'est
que vraiment casimir est trop gourmand
et le pire c'est qu'il met son
imagination au service de sa gourmandise
il faudrait trouver une punition pour
lui faire comprendre qu'il a fait un
gros mensonge oh vous avez entièrement
raison mon charme devrions lui le privé
de dessert ce soit inutile messieurs du
snav il m'a fait une commande pour son
goût bulgare qui pourra durer au moins
une semaine et bien moi je propose tout
simplement et de lui interdire de
quitter sa chambre pendant toute une
journée à pardonner maman cher ami mais
en tant que président de la fête des
lieux enfants je m'oppose à cette idée
cela priverait les enfants oh et puis il
adore rester dans sa chambre jouer alors
qu'à côté il faudrait quand même trouvé
quelque chose il faudrait marquer le
coup ils se sentent qu'ils enduraient
surtout que lui alors il ne se fait pas
faute d'inventer les farces julie chu
l'isi mais ça y est mais la voilà l'idée
il faut prendre les même punition que
casimir
de lui couper les oreilles on pointe
comme il voulait que je le fasse à
messieurs du snob la très bonne idée
julie oui pas si bonne que ça mes chers
amis vous semblez oublier que casimir
n'a pas d'oreille